hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys requested as soon as it
finished it's from today's Tata still
India Blitz tournament uh the rapid is
now over the rapid Was Won by MBL and
now we are into the Blitz and this is
the third round of the blitz section
it's pagna and the versus Vincent kymer
and uh Prague did the very well in Blitz
he got third place in blitz so Vincent
got eighth place but Vincent defeated
praga sorry in the rapid Vincent
defeated frog in the rapid section and
now is a fine opportunity for Prague at
uh well retaliate against Vincent and
this uh remember this is a Blitz game so
the game that you will see now uh is so
incredible so precise that it's very
hard to believe that it was actually
played in a blitz setting so now let's
dive straight into it Prague has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 uh
Vincent goes for Pawn to E6 sorry Pawn
to C6 he goes for the Karo Khan D4 D5
and progos for the exchange variation of
the Karo Khan with captors captures and
Bishop to D3 uh C4 is still a bit more
popular but Bishop to D3 is the second
most popular option with Knight to F6
Knight F3 Knights the C6 and C3 adding a
Defender here Bishop to G4 and now Pawn
to H3 with Bishop to H5 and Bishop to F4
so this is the the main line nothing new
being played here and they are just the
blitzing out moves as both of them know
this very well Bishop to D6 with Bishop
characters Queen captures and both of
them just castled here castles castles
and The Rook to E1 and this is basically
where this setup begins as black now has
uh any move is an option for black you
could play Rook B8 Rook C8 rookie eight
Rook after C8 you could play A6 you
could play Knight to back to D7 you
could play Bishop to G6 so those are all
ideas and black can play them in any
ordered uh well all depends on what
black wants to achieve here so Vincent
goes for Queen to C7 and now we have uh
Ponte A4 now there are a couple of games
where Queen to C2 and queen to B1 were
played but A4 is a new move so now as of
move 13 we have a completely new game
it's okay Ponte A6 and now Rook the e 3
already a very nice rock lift because
the Rook cannot be contested the Knight
cannot reach the rook and it's on a dark
Square so you don't have to worry about
the light core Bishop later on you might
move the Knight and put the Rook on G3
to go after the black king Rook 8 to B8
preparing to strike with B5 and now
Queen to F1 uh stopping this for the
moment is now the pawn bishop and queen
are fighting against Pawn to B5 so of
course the Vincent's a bishop on H5 now
that the queen move from D1 isn't all
that useful so let's remove uh one of
prague's strongest pieces and that is
the bishop on D3 okay product trades we
have captors captures and now Queen to
D3 activating the queen a little bit
more Rook after C8 you could go B5 right
away but first Vincent wants to improve
Knight to B3 and now Knight to D7
stopping Knight to C5 uh we have Knight
to G5 Now by playing on the queen side
Prague basically a forced Vincent to
move his pieces over to the queen side
and now uh the black king is kind of
exposed so Queen to F4 the forcing
product deal with the undefended Knight
on G5 and now Rook the G3 onto B5 now
and Rook to G4 chasing the black queen
back Queen to F5 offering a queen trade
and Prague very elegantly declines this
with Queen to G3 uh Knight to F6 now
attacking the rook and The Rook to F4
now the queen is attacked and Vincent
moves it to the C2 and this is now sort
of a problem because the B2 Pawn is
saying and also Knights the H5 is coming
with a fork on the queen and the Rook so
what does Prague do uh Prague just
ignores both of the threats and he plays
Knight to C5 and now uh what do you do
here do you capture on B2 do you go
after material with Knight to H5 both of
those moves are are fine and the engine
in fact says that you could play any of
these two moves and your you know your
position is very much okay with black
even better so Vincent goes for Knight
to the H5 with a nice Fork here Queen to
H4 and he grabs material Knight captures
on F4 Queen captures an F4 and now how
do you defend against Queen captures on
F7 well you can't really play a rook to
f8 you can play Rook to C7 as the queen
guards um at the C7 square and if you go
a rook to f8 then you go Queen H4 and
the black king does not have the f8
square to escape so instead after Queen
captures an F4 F6 is the move that
Vincent has to play it is the strongest
move and of course he plays it but that
means that he will now have the part
with his E6 Pawn so Knight G captures on
E6 and now B captures an A4 or you could
capture with the queen on B2 but this
makes more sense as The Rook wants to
come to B2 to put pressure on the F2
pawn and now uh proc plays Knight
captures on A4 which is uh again
incredibly precise for Blitz if you I I
was even that interested in in this
position that I allowed the engine to
Crunch the numbers up to depth 50 and it
it is the absolute best move the other
move that you might Place Queen to D6
because why not just Checkmate the
blacking right away the problem is root
capture some B2 and now you you you have
the F2 pawn undefended and if Rook to F1
now you think the h8 is very strong and
now if Queen to D7 of course Rook to G8
and you you can even give up a piece
here if Queen characters in C6 the A3
Pawn is just winning for black so that
that's a problem so proc plays the
absolute best Knight captures on A4 uh
Queen to F5 Vincent again offers the
queen trade and now Prague against uh
again uh well declines but what a way to
decline the queen trade this is uh it's
very hard to to calculate this and I I
have uh problems even uh you know
comprehending that calculated this in a
Blitz game so I'm just going to show it
to you otherwise I'd make this a pause
the video moment but uh you you do not
calculate this so I have no idea how
Prague did it but let's just show it uh
he played Queen to D6 which of course
makes sense if it works but what if it
doesn't now even with the absolute best
defense by Vincent let's say Rook to E8
goes after the Knight now Knights the C7
and again progress back into the game
attacks The Rook uh puts pressure on the
pawn here and if rookie 2 goes going
after the F2 Pawn he will just trade
Queens captures with check Wing captors
Knight captures and okay Vincent is up
the exchange but Prague is up two pawns
and his position is better uh so it's a
very passive uh position to go uh in for
Vince and especially against two knights
you know in Blitz two knights are
basically three Knights uh so Vincent
played Pawn to G5 this is again the
second strongest move recommended by the
engine and a you know more of a human
movie because it gives the G6 Square to
the black queen to defend against
Checkmate but now look at what proc
found Queen to D7 presence Checkmate
Queen to G6 and now look at this Knight
to B6 attacks The Rook uh you can't
really move the Rook anywhere uh well
the Knight on C6 would be hanging so the
only move for Vincent is Queen to F7 and
now look at this queen captures an F7
King captures and now Knight captures on
C8 we have Rook sorry King captures on
E6 uh okay uh Prague got his material
back but the Knight here is stuck on C8
so what's the idea here is probably just
gonna be down tonight in this end game
nope Prague actually found Knight to A7
and uh without finding this Knight the
A7 move at that moment where he played
Queen to D6 when Vincent offered a queen
trade I don't see how Prague would
actually commit the queen to D6 so he
saw this Knight to A7 move at the time
that he played Queen to D6 or you know
you could call it luck but I I wouldn't
say that these players uh rely unlock
that much so I'm gonna call it um that
he calculated it and now there is no way
for black to uh avoid losing the game
now the problem is of course if you
capture then Rook captures an A6 comes
with check and he wins back the night
and if you move the Knight then just
throw captures on A6 and he wins more
material so Vincent had to trade here
Knight captures an A7 Rook captures an
A6 with check and now King to F5 uh we
have Rook captures on A7 winning back
the night and now Rook captures on B2
Rook captures on G7 and now Rook the C2
going after the pawn here and Rook the
C7 proc defends the pawn and Prague is
now up two pawns but okay for Vincent he
does have the incredibly active King so
uh he will probably be able to minimize
this two and uh to a one Pawn Advantage
so King to E4 rooked the E7 check King
to D3 and now Rook the E3 with check for
the moment defending King to C4 and now
G3 and this is the problem and um this
game is like a poem uh you could
actually trade Rooks here even though
you're down a pawn if if not for this
Pawn being on F6 it's that silly uh the
idea is after Rook captures Rook
captures with check and King captures H4
wins the game for Prague as you probably
expected but the problem is after King
captures on D4 H5 uh King to E5 and H6
there is no King F6 the just the the
pawn being an F6 loses the game for
black so if it was on F5 or an F7 it'd
be fine but it hits an F6 so it doesn't
work you have to waste the move or you
know go around and the king is just not
in time to reach the pawn so very very
strange here I mean uh of course I I
don't think uh Prague calculated all the
way to here when he played Queen to D6
but still very very nice so Ponte F5
Vincent says all right I need my Pawn to
be an F5 in order for my king to win
this race but now Prague of course just
gets the uh the extra Tempo that he
needs spawn to H4 and now he's ahead in
the race with G4 King to G2 and now Rook
the A2 again he cannot trade uh we have
Rook the E5 and now Rook the A5
defending so he can start gobbling up
pawns here Rook captures on F5 King
captures and C3 and now Rook to F4
defending and attacking and he was in
this position on move 46 that Vincent
kaimer resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so Prague
didn't just uh get his revenge on
Vincent he also uh is the leader after
the first day of the Tata steel India
Blitz after nine rounds and he started
by winning with five out of five I think
yeah with five out of five uh and then
okay he he suffered some losses and then
he won the final game I think I even
have it here no sorry that's for the
next video I'm just going to check it
real quickly uh so give me a second uh
give me a second I don't want to trick
you guys uh there we go yeah he started
by winning uh yeah five out of five so
he defeated uh the job of mvl Vincent
now in round three he defeated abusatron
in round four uh Hari Krishna around
five dinner dragons grishock then he
loses two games to visit and bukash and
then he defeats Arjun uh in around nine
so he is the leader after the first day
uh the standings being Prague with six
and a half visit with six grishock with
six then we have with four and a half
Arjun irrigation with four mvl and Abdu
satrov in Hari Krishna kaimer uh in
ninth place with three and a half and
rajabov in last place with two points at
the moment so we'll see if Prague can
keep this up until the very end but you
know if he will be playing like this and
once again this is Blitz like everything
you've seen in this game is Blitz if if
you've seen this in a classical game
you'd probably say okay of course it's a
masterpiece like this is you know it's
classical you have time oh no this is
blitz so incredible stuff by Prague
we'll see what happens I interested the
tournament and the standings that I
accidentally showed you now are actually
for my next video that I already have
planned and it's a very special one it's
a classical game from 1981 between Gary
kasparo and tignan petrossian uh the the
at that time the former world champion
facing the future world champion and I I
can tell you guys it's it's such an
incredible game you guys who really want
to see it I will post it at 9 00 PM
Central European Time so you know uh
stay tuned for that but yeah and once
again really hope you guys enjoyed this
I would like to thank obvious mimic.com
Gerard Princeton bon bon Solon baby boo
girls niches festival.org.gg and Amanda
Oliver the most beautiful girl in the
world for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and everything else that
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day